depuis 30 ans qu'il fait ce métier il le
reconnaît son cœur n'est plus tout à
fait le même il doit être réglé sur
autre chose simplement il se sent
beaucoup plus jeune
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi est-ce que vous donnez le temps
de mal pour conserver cette horloge vous
pourriez électrifier
c'est-à-dire que on est bien conservé en
fait moi personnellement je suis un peu
conservateur parce que tout de même
c'est pas comparer une rose mécanique
avec une petite horloge électrique qui
représente presque rien du tout quoi et
puis alors c'est plus vivant quoi c'est
pas un point de vue c'est mieux une
pendule mécanique qu'on voit un
balancier tandis que les petites
pendules électriques qu'est-ce qu'on va
avoir des aiguilles qui marchent il a la
charge 30 horloge mécanique disséminée
un peu partout dans Paris ils doivent
être montés les unes tous les mois les
autres tous les 15 jours
chaque horloge à son jour de visite il
pourrait les faire électrifier pour la
plupart il est le patron de son propre
service et faire remplacer comme il dit
par les petites boîtes électriques
ils préfèrent les conserver comme elles
sont monter et descendre des escaliers
tourner et remonter les poids il trouve
qu'elles sont belles
il va mettre un quart d'heure pour
remonter les poires de Saint-Germain de
Charonne et s'il arrive trop tard c'est
les poids touchent le sol alors le câble
sort des poulies et il ne reste plus
qu'à s'en aller chercher une grande
échelle
[Musique]
la plus belle pièce de son musée privé
l'horloge monumentale de l'hôtel de
ville
[Musique]
il a sauvé de la poussière des oiseaux
et surtout des gens qui tenaient en
porter des petites pièces en passant
[Musique]
Notre Dame de la croix
153 marche à graver et qui toutes ne
sont pas toujours facile à trouver
[Musique]
une horloge mère dans une rue de Paris
pour retrouver leur exacte
je peux pas du si on rentre pas tout de
même d'acheter excusez-moi on rentre pas
comme dans un moulin dans vos églises
vous demandez les clés à qui qui
appartiennent en principe les
appartiennent à l'église il faut aller à
la sacristie et se renfermés dans un
placard et chaque porte a une clé
différente
mais nous on connaît les nôtres parce
que il y a une petite étiquette ou bien
on sait l'endroit où elle est approchée
en permanence est-ce que vous êtes
arrivé de
pratiquement d'être enfermé dans un
clocher oui une fois une fois plusieurs
fois même mais une fois là à
saint-etienne-des-monts et puis alors
pour me faire délivrer il a fallu que je
somme les cloches
le sacrétaire est venu c'est demandé
qu'est-ce qu'il y avait il est venu
m'ouvrir il a entendu
des causes
et puis c'était moi qui était enfermé
dans le clocher
Saint-Germain l'Auxerrois
une horloge en fer forgé qui date de 300
ans
et dont il est le seul gardien et aussi
le seul visiteur
je suis tombé je suis resté pendant près
d'une heure et sans connaissance et puis
après je suis revenu à moi-même j'aurais
pu être enfermé et puis mourir même dans
le prochain
non parce que pratiquement personne n'y
vient jamais dans ses clochettes non il
n'y a que nous si on a affaire puisqu'on
a fait aux horloges à part quelques fois
qu'il y a les ouvriers de les couvreurs
ou bien des électriciens
pourquoi est-ce que les pigeons aiment
tellement les clochers
le carillon du Louvre 38 cloches pesant
10 tonnes un dos qui pèse à lui tout
seul deux tonnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un quart d'heure pour déjeuner
jamais d'alcool
un coup d'œil sur le monde extérieur
particulièrement des ordonné
et puis le voilà reparti
depuis 30 ans qu'il fait ce métier il
leur connaît son cœur n'est plus tout à
fait le même il doit être réglé sur
autre chose
simplement il se sent beaucoup plus
jeune
[Musique]
et quand il vient pas cet accès
nous avons recours par exemple à
l'échelle des pompiers si le crochet est
très haut on commence nous avons une
échelle de 15 m mais si c'est beaucoup
plus haut par exemple à l'église
Jeanne d'Arc il a fallu faire appel à
l'échelle des pompiers de 33 mètres
combien d'années encore de la fermeture
quelques années
est-ce que vous reviendrez voir une
meilleure base oui je veux bien les voir
de temps en temps
vous allez vous établir encore
dans mon village
dans le jardin moi en tout cas je vais
mettre un cas je vais faire une
intervention
[Musique]